believe it or not this moment was
brought to you by two brothers who
turned a bowling tournament into a
three-day Music Festival we made a party
basically you know anyone can bowl and
you can drink while you bowl so it makes
it even that more fun this is Sean Stern
he and his brother Mark started Punk
Rock Bowling more than two decades ago
we had a 2017 teams uh but it was a
great party it was a lot of fun and we
said ah we'll do this again next year
and the next year we sold out at one
point they had 200 teams so it was time
to do with any DIY rocker would do go to
Vegas baby once my stages get in and
placed I'll have a crew of roughly 20.
after 60 years the outdoor Festival
returns to 6th and Stewart Kathy Mason
will pile up the fence over there is the
festival director most of the bands that
play here I've been on tour with for
several years rancid Bad Religion all of
them a Warped Tour regular Mason will
now help Wrangle 42 bands at the outdoor
three-stage venue and then at night
there are shows at six venues including
the Citrus pool and sand dollar
Vegas's own teen sibling Rock sensation
the doll heads will open the monster
stage on Saturday we're gonna play we're
trying to keep it like really high
energy and they're ready to see you hit
the pit and bang it out to some Classics
and Fresh Faces just like them there are
a lot of great bands and a lot of
legendary punk bands so like just come
it will be a really great time